il passe inaperçu dans les rues d'haïti
ils ont généralement entre 7 18 ans
privés de leur enfance leur liberté leur
dignité
stéphanie à 12 ans depuis le séisme
saviez de l'enfer toujours un parcours
les deux barquettes ses parents sont
morts sous les décombres de la maison
une femme l'a sauvée pour aussitôt la
mettre au travail
elle me bat 116 dit-elle encore et
encore
elle refuse de me donner à manger parce
que je ne travaille pas assez vite
l'histoire de stéphanie pas unique dans
ce centre de jour où l'on apprend à
l'artisanat aux filles restent avec
longtemps de porter leur cause devant
les tribunaux surtout elles vivent
toutes le même drame
oui c'est de l'esclavagé parce que
proviseur c'est parce que simon sait si
mon physique des dix ans comme au québec
en moins 50 ans un véritable esclavage
qui révolte d'autant plus les militantes
comme à la villa aides que la société
haïtienne
le tolère l'histoire des restes avec est
pourtant bien simple pour parents trop
pauvres ils ont placé dans une famille
qui a promis de payer leurs études ils
deviennent plutôt des esclaves
domestiques nous le ménage la
préparation des repas que tu passes qui
fait mener momiji m'bina chaque jou
varane 18 ans est l'une de ses victimes
orpheline du séisme son drame s'est
déplacé dans la promiscuité de ce qu
entre la capitale et saint gildas on ne
fait pas les gens
cinq fils de sa belle-mère love you lie
encore et encore elle ignore lequel de
ses agresseurs est le père de son enfant
la menace du viol est telle que même
celles qui ont été épargnées n'en
peuvent plus non pas que mon affaire de
samson m et vanessa est hanté par la
peur de subir le même sort est basse et
autorités au palais pas décidé boulot
fait rien
le pire c'est que les autorités ne font
rien n'ose pas s'attaquer au problème
explique la responsable du centre de
jour cette violence donc peut durer des
années
les ressources pour venir en aide à ces
jeunes filles sont bien minces ici à
port au prince par exemple on compte les
refuges sur les doigts d'une main pour
protéger l'identité des victimes
ils sont cachés dans le dédale des rues
et les ruelles
l'un d'eux a accepté de nous ouvrir ses
portes à condition que l'on protège
l'anonymat des pensionnaires tout pour
empêcher leurs familles de les retrouver
un groupe de femmes d'une militante
veille sur elle je vivais avec une
personne qui m'avait rendu esclaves
donc moi même j'étais impuissant temps
je ne pouvais rien faire
donc maintenant je veux les aider moi
même au logis sur l'embryon bon appétit
les pensionnaires si remercie le ciel de
la sécurité
de pouvoir enfin manger à leur faim
timide blessés l'une d'elles nous
demandent de pouvoir livrer son terrible
secret les nanos quand il fait sienne le
mari de la dame lab mabuse et
sexuellement
c'est la première fois qu'elle en parle
ouvertement soutenu par l'affection de
ses protectrice n'est pas mon cas
mais pour rebondir et comment tu te sens
ici
on sent tout ok ça si les livres et je
me sens bien c'est une dérive os brisé
le silence c'est la seule arme dont
disposent ces jeunes filles pour lutter
contre les justice pour le viol en haïti
normalement on le fait souvent pourquoi
on le fait souvent c'est parce que et
les petites voix qui peuvent soulever
son taux faibles sont trop faibles
elle n'est pas la seule alors qu'il
réapprenne à rire et à juifs six jeunes
filles passeront 18 mois d'une refuge le
temps de commencer à guérir et la
majorité des restes avec comme la petite
stéphanie doivent rentrer tous les soirs
chez leurs agresseurs
elle elle s'accroche à son rêve le rêve
de devenir un jour médecin
emmanuelle latraverse radio-canada port
au prince